tu est une énorme pince a longtemps j'ai
déjeuné avec lui alors j'ai réglé
l'addition il a pris le ticket pour ce
thriller
[Applaudissements]
je veux que les marches ce sont ben
c'est toutes les fins ils sont présentés
pour quel motif une info de ouf à daisy
j'ai appris que mathieu
[Rires]
lorsque mathieu va au restaurant oui
donc souvent dans paris des beaux
restaurants parce que mathieu a beaucoup
de goût comme on le sait ouais à la fin
quand il a terminé de manger les rots
qu'est ce qui dit aux serveurs ouais
c'est honteux il dit lui chez matthieu
delormeau il dit est-ce que je vous dois
quelque chose
[Rires]
j'ai entendu ça et franchement je me
suis dit est ce qu'un jour
on va en parler
qu'est ce qu'il avait en tête pour avoir
un sens qu'il a en tête c'est papy